tiempo de proteger a los líderes
sociales en Colombia este viernes antes
de la toma de posición del presidente
Gustavo Petro y la vicepresidenta
Francia Márquez un grupo de
organizaciones presentó un plan de
emergencia para que el gobierno trace un
proyecto que proteja a los líderes
sociales y a los firmantes del acuerdo
de paz entre el estado colombiano y la
extinta guerrilla de las FARC el plan se
presenta sobre cinco ejes la presencia
del estado y los territorios más
violentos la puesta en marcha de medidas
de acción preventiva por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad la administración
de la justicia y la persecución de la
impunidad la toma de acciones para
generar confianza institucional y la
gestión de riesgos y ayuda humanitaria
el objetivo de la propuesta pasa por
proteger la vida de los liderazgos
sociales tras un periodo donde la
violencia aumento significativamente los
territorios colombianos las agresiones
contra los liderazgos sociales han ido
aumentando progresivamente
no solo los homicidios que es lo que más
se registra los homicidios que se
necesitan contra los liderazgos sociales
y los firmantes de paz sino también las
amenazas las desapariciones forzadas las
judicializaciones según el instituto de
paz y desarrollo durante el ejecutivo de
Iván Duque hubo más de 950 líderes
sociales y 261 firmantes de paz
asesinados el plan de emergencia cuya
implementación está prevista en los 100
primeros días de gobierno debe dar
respuesta a esta emergencia que va de la
mano de la implementación de una
búsqueda Asimismo complicada de la paz
total con los grupos armados ilegales
[Música]